never have i ever
uh borrowed money from a partner
i did ladies are drinking
okay
what happened i had just moved to miami
i didn't have a job yet and my rent was
short three hundred dollars
so i had to borrow from the guy that i
was dating and i paid him back like the
second i got my paycheck which was maybe
three days later and it was like the
most mortifying thing i've ever done why
did it feel so horrible
um
i have nothing against a guy spoiling me
but i do i don't like asking i feel like
it's really like it puts me in a
position where i'm
needy and i and that's like independence
to me is the most important
thing they love doing it
i i mean it's great if they love doing
it and i love that too like i'm not
gonna lie like my biological brain is
like oh man provides
um but uh
but i i i'm so
in love with being independent yeah and
i wouldn't give it up for anything and i
definitely don't want to have to ask for
you know extra help yeah i don't i don't
do it for my parents so i'm not going to
do it for myself do you worry about
being obligated for other things if you
accept absolutely
explain yeah great question rolo well if
it's a partner already then it's not as
right like you're willing to exactly you
know like i'm already with you yeah but
if it was like a friend or a guy you
kind of knew
there would be some sort of obligation
gotcha
yeah a little bit
and i'm not afraid that i'll do
something that i don't want to do i'm
afraid that i'll have to
have an awkward conversation of like hey
that's you know
remember that money you owe me yeah
so what happened with you tori uh i
parked downtown chicago and my car got
towed and i couldn't get i didn't have
enough money to take it out because my
wallet was in the car
and i don't know if you've ever gotten
your cards out there but yeah
i never paid that back
so what'd you do
he paid for it the dude paid for it yeah
and then what happened
and then what i was dating him okay
gotcha was a guy so we banged
sex
thanks dad
rolo what are your thoughts on these
girls asking you guys i've never
borrowed money from you before um i have
had women give me money before really
yes for what on somebody they're
swindler types
my rockstar 20s um but i have been with
women who have like bought me things
nice things but it hasn't been like oh i
was out of money or i was like i needed
help with the rent or anything like that
it was more like a gift kind of thing i
guess okay um no i was the reason i was
asking about the obligation is because i
think that a lot of girls will not uh or
they they're hesitant they have to get
to a point of like real desperation if
they uh if they accept sort of a
i hate that it seems like a bribe you
know or it's an obligation like oh
here's here's some don't worry baby i
got it for you and then like i think a
lot of women don't want independent or
not don't want to take that
um because they'll feel obligated to do
something or to like be a certain way
because the guy actually stepped up and
like paid your rent well let me get your
car out you're married you've been
married for 20 plus 20 right now so it
doesn't i mean when when it's your wife
who's kind of you share the intellect
she borrows from me sure okay so my
question is you ever like paid
for like i used to have a girl that
lived with me and she didn't have a job
and i would pay her to help me out and
it was like an awkward business dating
relationship yeah but it was like my
girl like she lives with me
baby yeah is that what it is yeah it's a
sugar baby yeah i feel like a sugar baby
doesn't live with you no they do
there's different types [ __ ] that was my
girlfriend this whole time but have you
ever had to pay for a girl that lived
with you no not
the only woman i've ever really lived
with is my wife but like i mean when i
was living down in north hollywood back
in the day um it was
you know it wasn't really a uh it wasn't
really an issue i think it was more like
um i mean i was playing uh playing a
part playing a role that like women
wanted to be a part of at that time and
so that's how you get like you know oh
let me buy you a leather jacket let me
buy you this did you ever watch um did
you ever watch the the dirt on the
netflix with vermotley crew like back in
the day and like i watched joe jordan
vince neil was like living with his
girlfriend and she would like buy him
those leather the leather pants are very
an important part of that documentary
yeah that's what i'm talking about right
there is is
gifts kind of thing gotcha gifting all
right let's have a way of expressing
love it's
one of your love language gifting
yeah i like making but also
receiving or giving
i like well both i mean i have all the
languages of love obviously but my main
one would probably be quality time okay
and active service
shout out to you
[Music]